hello and welcome to this video playing
Grand Master geheime pullets I the
secret police forgot three out of three
against um okay I pc-6 is a bit more
precise but ok it's not a it's not a big
deal
might be five I have to prevent that
it's be a little bit annoying there with
this bit with the bishop oh ok
immediately react stood it was necessary
really could have played down less
committal moves yeah I came so I'm going
to let some pre Mafia you never know
okay well I takes with the bishop
surprisingly ok I have to support d5 a
little bit edgy six-night h4 something
that I would like to get in
okay not really sure that it takes but I
it's actually very unlikely move I don't
need to remove that if it's not
happening
not easy to handle for him whenever he
takes he activates me and I'm having
some pressure on g4 and so on it's not
easy for y to play this position okay so
he gives me G for the exchange will be
seven at least that's possible okay
I can also just take you five and two
Queen to h4 is a move let's do this and
go Queen to h4 f5 I'll take you five and
maybe you can take and go at five hmm
maybe maybe yeah I can go by five I
probably have to take on g4 then and
then it looks a lot like a draw yeah I
didn't want to allow a draw in this
position I like my position cringy for
tips on g6 Queen takes d4 is a draw by
am by repetition
hmm really don't want to draw but it's
hard to not to not play this really hard
I guess I have to check check check
shanghai i wanted to play for window
didn't check workout brown are dry gin
that's a bit disappointing really like
my position there yeah it is it is
better for black I can the entrance is
just this which avoids the drawings yeah
it's probably good for me next position
is very unstable this is hanging this is
hanging and those pieces say especially
the queen is off yeah here after f5 I
have to have to make the drawer I cannot
do anything else yeah I'm interesting I
think I had something very comparable in
earlier game and I choose 6 lakh will be
3 is wrong yeah here I can still do this
and play for win something like that
computer wants to go here yeah the way I
played I had to make the draw there's
absolutely check check no way out here i
cannot i don't i don't have any pieces
here to to join the attack so that I can
continue
is I have to be content with the draw
here okay well thanks for watching